nous passons à une question de notre
collègue madame patricia mohr erichot
pour le groupe des républicains
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur ministre les magistrats
français sont confrontés à toujours plus
de missions avec toujours moins de
moyens
l'insécurité croissante dans laquelle le
pays est plongé aggravent la situation
des tribunaux devant le nombre
d'affaires à traiter la conférence des
procureurs de france a annoncé le
désengagement du parquet dans les
procédures jugés non prioritaires
voilà qui ouvre encore plus largement la
voie à l'impunité
on observe une grande disparité de
délais de jugement sur le territoire la
justice n'est plus la même pour tous sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
dans les hautes-alpes on compte en
théorie trois magistrats un procureur et
deux substituts puisque le vice
procureur est à temps partiel c'est
pourtant cette même équipe amputée de
20% qui doit assumer toutes les
audiences l'ensemble des permanences des
réunions à l'extérieur et bien sûr les
déplacements dans un département qui n'a
pas été épargné avec 45 personnes
décédées en montagne pour l'année 2015
alors que notre société se judiciarise
que la délinquance augmente
le ministère public est happé par la
lutte contre la radicalisation sans
aucun moyen moyen supplémentaire
certaines juridictions sont asphyxiés
nous avons bien compris monsieur le
ministre que vous estimiez que la
justice est à bout de souffle
vous venez de faire un terrible héritage
monsieur le ministre quelles mesures
concrètes
allez-vous mettre en place pour que
l'institution judiciaire reprennent une
activité normale
pas seulement à bobigny où vous avez
fait des annonces mais dans tout
l'hexagone
la parole est à monsieur le garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
oui monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice je vais pas faire de polémique
parce que je pourrais en faire et j'ai
choisi de traiter la justice pour ce
qu'elle est c'est à dire un élément qui
doit être un armand de rassemblement il
ya aujourd'hui 480 postes de magistrats
qui ne sont pas pourvus à cela il ya une
expression et une raison très simple
c'est qu'en 2008 en 2009 en 2010 mais ce
sont des faits c'est pas une polémique
ce sont les faits si si si il y avait eu
si vous voulez juste un jeu cherche ni à
faire des effets mais simplement à ce
que chacun 105 poste 105 postes pendant
trois ans cette année il y en a 3 168 en
termes de greffiers il y avait ces
années-là moins de 200 postes
quand on est ministre de la justice
madame et qu'on n'ouvre 105 postes
pendant trois ans alors que l'on sait
qu'à la même période il y en aura 1400
qui vont partir à la retraite sous
quatre ans ont construit la
paupérisation de la justice
vous me forcer à dire la vérité je vais
vous la donne et voulait les chiffres je
vais vous dire vous êtes dans une
juridiction qui justement est éjection
préserver il y a trois sièges au parquet
ils sont occupés
il y a neuf sièges au ciel ils sont
occupés il manque deux fonctionnaires
deux adjoints administratifs ils seront
comblés au mois de septembre
il n'y aura pas un effectif qui manquera
à gap malheureusement toutes les
juridictions ne peuvent pas en dire
autant
parce que les efforts que nous faisons
demanderont du temps à s'appliquer mais
je vous invite à venir avec moi à
l'école nationale de l'administration de
domaine de la magistrature pardon saluts
et saluts et les 368 fonctionnaires et
venir avec moi à l'école nationale des
greffes salué les 761 greffier que nous
allons embaucher
madame mori riche vous pouvez répliqué à
monsieur le ministre garde des sceaux
monsieur ministre voilà quatre ans que
votre majorité gouverne le budget de la
justice par habitant classe désormais la
france au 37e rang en europe juste
derrière l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
je crois monsieur le ministre qu'il ya
urgence à se consacrer aux vrais
problèmes des français aux vrais
problèmes de la justice
il n'y a pas de temps à perdre dans
d'hypothétiques réforme
constitutionnelle soyez concrets sans
ordre réorganisation sans moyens sans
révision des règles qui régissent la
procédure pénale nous nous éloignerons
d'une justice sereine et efficace